AI is the tractor and for the people
understand we're saying here it is most
people worked on farms back in the day
and then a tractor came out and
everyone's like [__] that we're all out
of [__] jobs
and then people found new jobs
so what do I think I think you can have
any opinion you want technology doesn't
give a [__] about your opinion it's
going to do what it's going to do and
it's not gonna stop so if you do a job
that AI is capable of doing soon
you should think about that do you
understand I gave this same keynote in
1997 the analogy I used then was look if
you're the top salesman or sales woman
for the Yellow Pages you might want to
consider what Yahoo and Google are doing
so what do I think about AI I think it's
coming I think it's coming fast and it's
going to be awesome and there's going to
be certain rule changes and humans have
proven to me that they have the ability
to adjust to the new reality and deal
with